now there is a podcast with a video about
the german walt disney the german
walt disney lives in freiburg
in baden and there is europapark rust for
work meanwhile 5000 people
half a billion turnover a huge park
the whole area there is dominated by
the kaisers park is and how  he did
it 175 he builds on it that you can
do everything on your own can investors an
incredibly inspiring story has
come into the
conversation may
be incredible or what you put
here yes said before in
the brief encounter sometimes i
don't believe myself what it came from  when
i have my quiet minute and go for
a run, sometimes climb up the tower
or go to a hotel you should be
lucky over the whole park or
now like at the weekend with the
balloon fly over the park with the balloon flyer
there  one wonders what
it all came into being, it obviously means yes, even in
the hand
so we have to we are the trip to
shows that is meanwhile important
medium-sized companies i've
already heard about 5000 people they
employ here and then of
course have to peak seasonally but
probably know who so that's possible
feeling for the size yes
but it is  started for me 19 75
when you thought about it i'm going to build
an amusement park here
it wasn't that easy the family
history is a bit
older we're almost 250 years old
it all started in 1780 in a small
town in the black forest  near
freiburg my great, great, great
ancestors
built vehicles landau built for
agriculture and then later made the systems for two
courses and
showmen and in this respect we were already
in contact with the entertainment industry
and then at the beginning of the 70s we came up with the
idea we  we could do it
ourselves and we felt there was a
gap in the market in German  country that you
don’t approach a city with a population of millions
and go
where most people live, we assume that
in the ruhr area it has
something to do with loyalty to one’s homeland
, of course, we already
had the a5 traffic axis in mind,
probably the entire holiday traffic  direction
spain italy also flow into switzerland
and that was then our approach
to look for a site which is due to this
international traffic says it is
and so the idea was born relatively clearly
in modest both gal hovering over
rust was in the newspapers
no one believed the success  but that's the way it is
with many startups today nobody
believes you're going and later they
're suddenly how
big would the company be when the
deal with the park so this
mack rides it's already called like the
rides the nucleus how big was
this company  since even if we now had
millions of business that was already it was of
course there was already a company in
the bran  che was very
important we supplied all the parks not all the
folk festivals in germany
they were a company that mainly
processed domestic orders and even if
they were it was exciting when you
see how this company
has changed from 100 percent in the last forty fifty years  domestic 100
percent export or almost 100%
exporters the folk festivals in hamburg in
stuttgart in munich the oktoberfest
supplies the maxim the luxury caravans
built for the showmen
choose transportable we built
the mobile roller coasters the mobile
rides we were really at the most
well-known and largest manufacturers  there
was a real boom in the industry after the war
we had
between 100 and 150 employees but
we also had an extended
workbench a lot was supplied at the time
to process the orders but of
course the
turnover was modest compared to what we do today i can be honest
on as my dad  transferred the
company when i came into the
management we were at 15
million marks sales are 78 million euros
and belonged at that time with these sales
to the big ones in the industry in
germany there were the 26 then
I was 24
ok so very young
studied mechanical engineering at the university of karlsruhe
that was i was always a
technician for him but also
worked a lot in the yard during the holidays of
course the phase as a
small child was very exciting because everyone else wanted to
have put up windows looking out so
that in the bedroom and there are  then
the merry-go-rounds were created and
they were of course allowed to be tested
, so i invited my children
my friends invited children
from the town of waldkirch and
then i was of course a very
popular game
that's how i actually got
closer to the industry and we are always like that
I went to the folk
festivals again, sometimes with my father in
the wo  slept in the car from the
showmen to save money in the hotel
we visited two big ones i was allowed to give
the circus director flowers
so i have noticed the stench from childhood
on because it was clear to
me that i would become active in this branch
and that it would no longer happen  the craft
is all that matters because the business has also become noticeably
more international i
then decided to study mechanical engineering
ok what does it cost today
but eight but if you sell it
so if it can be delivered today as today
’s mack rides i think i think that in
the countries of something  what you
buy tickets for that is a huge range of
course it depends on the target group
it depends on who orders such a
facility a park has maybe five
million 10 million visitors that is
one day then has 500,000 visitors
but i would start the facilities sometime  say
3 12 million and can up to 50
million and beyond million
euros or dollars ko  most of these are
all unique there were of course certain
things
like now axles
vehicle frame rail dimensioning
that is taken over but otherwise
it is in the subjunctive märklin railway is
assembled piece by piece and inserted into the
terrain and that is what
actually makes the specialty of our
company that the  customer choose
money invested prototype gets
hall construction works but today's
initial business sales is
still relevant a smaller part like
percentage of turnover now it's still
so exciting that with the founding of
europa park where we always said
it should be a shop window for our products
we don't have a completely new
product line raised me systems
as if they are connected to the ground that
stands on foundations 2 is
not the case at the folk festival that has to be
dismantled within a week and who are
rebuilt and thus had the
actual shop window and were
more u  nd more
internationally perceived and
therefore the turnover of the showmen in
pike delivery has changed from zero to one
hundred and also an
exponent almost double it is interesting
that in this phase of the transformation
away from a pure carousel in
vehicle construction towards stationary systems
these are  all competitors in
germany fell by the wayside
mack rides is the only or with the
only company it was still working for the industry
okay but it is
still in your portfolio activities
smaller part maybe is the
smaller part but of course because of
the internationality and the
large systems that we are building today have
gained in importance so i would
say the 2 kilo company accounts for
22 of the total volume and 30 percent of the
sales volume from
the three largest worldwide
as manufacturers serve international trade fairs whether
that’s shanghai whether it’s
florida orlando whether it’s in major european
cities country  so  you
can find like systems around the world today and
then you also started
to build everything yourself for your own day
that's the end of the story now
you just took something that
just say how fast they are
available was available or because of what you
the first rides that was
interesting that we didn't actually pick from
the drawer and pulled
out existing systems
relatively easily because we still want to manufacture
the lonely new things have
already developed systems that are already custom-designed for this
park and there was also a
theme and  based on the topic
and also designed a completely new
product line, namely
stationary systems and europa park
was only their shop window from then on and
are the decisive
criterion in roller coasters or are that is meanwhile
there are quite a lot of times through the
park is experienced as a result  then
there is a theme world of any
a  rt there are not only eight but
there are also 13 roller coasters alone i
think the approach back then when the company
was founded was clearly pointing towards that gel
is also a bit comparable to
what they thought back then when he tried it
with his little girls in los
angeles  has found for the entire
family entertainment had
actually discovered nothing and that's when
the city or the founding
of disneyland arose that you build a
place where you can go with the whole
family he was smiled at the
showmen at that time large parts of the
usa with arrogance  the models from disney
looked at only flowers
landscaping only
building architecture four entrances should
have something like that disney only has one
entrance that will never work it works
unfortunately also got completely into
debt invested 17 million
dollars back then you have to imagine
that compared to today  an investment
at disney was maybe 100 million
kos  only one other person had
the whole case for 17
million at the time he was personally up to his
neck in debt because he also believed in
the company and
then had five million visitors in the first year
so it was a hit
1900 died in 1954 it started
is 55
and what exactly was our approach
it was always the approach of our
family not only
to ride spectacular rollercoasters but also to have a place where
the family can
enjoy grandpa father mother grandchild of
course there are other
scenes involved and show effects
garden architecture is part of it theme is part of it it
was clear right from the start we had
the means the financial means
to set up a theme park right from the start
but it was always clear
if things went reasonably well this
europa park would be named
after all name elections basically a
requirement  for what
is supposed to happen here, we definitely wanted to
leave  differ from the showman at a
folk
festival and that also includes hotels at the end of the day that
now also includes a second
day that includes events that includes
topics that are
not only implemented visually but also
in connection with an attraction of
course that also includes a roller coaster
that's not a roller coaster at all  ask if you have more than
five million visitors about six
million visitors again dad then you
can’t do without this big railway
ok but it started that
you bought your castle in the
area and were then allowed to use this castle
park as the nucleus
for today too  it is interesting
that courtly facilities in
particular were often a precursor to park development,
at least in europe you can of course you do
n't have to be aware that you
also followed a clear line and
shaped and developed everything
but here in europe there was already a
past  the courtly
tradition i think of advisors in  vienna
i'm thinking of an audience
locations was also basically a 1 1
pleasure garden liesenberg in
gothenburg as well and from this nice
tradition has settled there
that's why we have the
riester or also in scandinavia
older tradition like in germany and to
that extent  that was also the case
here the castle has on the
one hand something romantic on the
other hand of course it also has
a castle park and i told you before
that garden architecture in particular is
extremely important in landscaping
and that was of course a plus
wanted the castle park and decided
around a park that naturally had
a great atmosphere from the first minute
how did it start that people saw
it so it was you that you advertised
or somehow advertised it with
other
newspapers radio stations
the little people drive here
over on the autobahn but it's not
now  it's probably always
summer exciting rides
somewhere come right away the people now
have to be communicated somehow
also a courageous decision is
right because they say it was
n't known at the time of this kind
that means you had to
offer something that the customer didn't even have  I
really knew what it was, but
I think we received
relatively strong word-of-mouth propaganda right
from the start, and that brought us loyal
repeat customers. New customers
were generated as a result, of course, you still go to
the classic media such as radio and
television reporting back then
no internet and worries has
gradually made the price better known, which i found out in
the development that
we might not have seen it that way at the beginning
, although the term europa
park has become the proximity to switzerland, the proximity
to france and in the course of the
european development cindy borders
and these markets are extreme
important for us were a million over
a million visitors from switzerland
and over a million visitors from
france
the people from elzer the french love
these facilities i have big ones the
catchment area nowadays i received
the study yesterday from last
year the catchment area has an
average arrival time of  2
hours and 50 minutes
that means that's a considerable
radius from which the guests come on
average
than 300 kilometers and I mean long
in the 150 kilometers were the room
is the big city that's not next
door there live 25 30
million
people they were at the beginning but really
word of mouth classic radio television
a bit of advertising in the local
so that they to attract money yes of course we
approached everything very stepmotherly we come
from mechanical engineering is a manufacturer and we do
n't have to have service providers  the
first
hard to work out the gastronomy where  ll
we spent at the beginning because we
didn't have a relationship then we
didn't find a tenant because we didn't
believe in the success either. today it's
a mainstay in the economic
success of the park and so we
gradually worked our way up and
have continued to develop
I drive  I still remember
Kramer put up a sign one day from mack
rides it said it said over the next
seven years there will always be new
attractions
this had for seven years in any case
the sign then stood for 20 years because it can
move real estate
like that every year for the next seven years  something new
to add and i think that made the
park so attractive that we never
stopped developing,
went
up in quality and thus had a
fan base who were loyal to
us 80 percent repeaters that
is of course the basis of the  success it
really means these five million
visitors  a year nowadays 80
percent of them say they were there
last year or two years
ago, so someone who has
just been there
before is a repeater, that’s 80 percent ok to start with the financing
nowadays you take equity or
was it similar to  disney
also in debt and soon went to the banks
or everything is factory that basically
64 24 years later we had the same
situation we probably experienced
this no banks wanted to participate
equity my parents' house was in
debt up to the roof edge and
that was all  it cost me that my
father was also behind
this idea financially because he was so
convinced that he himself took the risk of water working
in the company margreiter for decades
because he was completely convinced of the success
okay that means it will be
now everything from our own funds we
had to back then my grandfather was a
founding member of  volksbank in
waldkirch the banks are all
even smaller and the credit volume
was not sufficient from our house
bank so that several
banks have joined forces to
cushion the credit risk and to
give the innkeepers the opening needed a
legal dimension but
either then but we have  30 million
is back then that was a
magnitude, especially if you are making
an investment in antique now
it's not like you
built something with 30 million everyone probably
said it has to be sold to the people but
the bankrupt vulture hovered where's the
ruins of leisure time  change but i'm
also very proud that we
did it that we hurt the lies
it's a good feeling if
you do a little research you can
see to this day there's a number 700
million has been
invested in the over the years  park
it is now no longer remarque euro
and that's nice  n important i mean these
are of course modest amounts
if then the grundinvest are 30 million marks
15 million euros today
who invest an average of 55 and 70
million euros a year just in
new rides the landlord and
also the extensions lentpark then the
hotel facilities was meanwhile
millions of euros have already been invested in hotels
that is also the
infrastructure is relatively expensive for the
expansion of all the development
measures is now of
course a completely different dimension
so i would just say you are
so in rust now this place is where it feels like it is
europa park  and groups about it
so you don't even know what was
actually there just now but
the mood of the former mayor and
we are there the last subject area of
yes exactly so roughly is it reall
like that so all these subje
ts give money and then you go there still have
there are also streets named after
your father or  they are named here
so you get the feeling you know you
've seen everything i've
but it's so that's also here of
course the biggest employer namely
everyone who lives here in rust has a
holiday room and additional business in the
summer because then people come
because  sleep in the rooms go to the park in the holidays
anyway it's like that all
hotels have had them so far we've
all built them yourself if you
built them yourself but of course there are
a lot of
providers as you say when you think about it we have
more almost more overnight stays like  the
city of freiburg this small
fishing village was basically still
looking for fish farming is
a tourist highlight will
be and the most popular tourist
locations the friendliest people doing
their services if you would
have thought 50 or 30 years ago
what  this place will become and
that everyone somewhere from this
tourist  depends on the local offer is of
course also a challenge that
you are integrated in such a village
that you stick together what you make
joint decisions we have
just presented another big
roller coaster the day before yesterday we are holding a citizens’ meeting and discussing it
with the citizens and interestingly enough it took
the form of a citizens’ meeting
we already changed 50 years ago after
church the mayor then went to
a pub called a few
citizens together and presented the
europa park project and at the
end he said rust will
wake up from his slumber and how
right he was the former mayor  and
that was basically an early form
of today's citizen participation of
the 200,000 inhabitants when we
started the interest was 400,000 so
basically it has doubled also comes
from the job situation
here the development opportunities we
have a great connection with l  eid through
the park to the a 5 is 20 minutes in
freiburg and 20 minutes in offenburg as a
man it's now also quite good that
every mayor probably first introduce
himself to you
or or let's not say that's
probably likely to be re-election
because there
was always a seminar by well, there were
headwinds, people
said we don't really want that and the place
is getting bigger and bigger it's a
completely different place now
than it was 20 years ago, that's
right, it's a mood
you have  but that's why
we decided early on to live here in the town
where we work and ultimately
also as a citizen of the community don't be
yourself meanwhile find your citizen
in the community but you have to
listen you have to talk to the people
we are  integrated into the association
, we help where we can
and of course we pick up on trends relatively early
on  we meet regularly with the
municipal council two or three times a
year, where we of course also hear what's going on
what's the mood like in the village what's the situation like,
but due to the pandemic, of
course it
felt like you should thank europa park
because it was relative here  quietly
seven months because the doors were
locked and no gates he came to us
and so many of you also
noticed what europe heard
if you live in rust, as a
citizen of rust you also have
lifelong free access
to the  park that means there are even people
who would just move here because
they love to go to the park and then
as citizens who could, so to speak, but otherwise
it's right because they say
but it's also nice to
be able to admire the
trade tax revenue here  of course, it often looked
pretty and became
really attractive
very good schools here in the village learn
craft businesses  what the apprenticeship
professions can do we have not far in
high schools nearby and with the advantage of being able to visit the park for free
it is already attractive from the
family and it is also recorded in the
land register in the land register so
that can no longer be done with the generation after me
change the mayor was
quite clever
and drives he is of course in the
shadow of the huge roller coaster and
that's why this skyline is
so important skyline so there
are roller coaster than as building land and
machines these different little
houses here it's nice is nice
unusual
and what i also noticed when
you run such a park there are
also all the trades
here so carpenters and actually
craftsmen of all stripes work here but also
about the story-telling films do that,
so to speak, in which the
media industry has everything round
the  park because of course a concept will be
developed there will be s  houses are
built around the animals that
is somehow a very rich
range of jobs there are absolutely me my
son needs all the
service providers all the manual
trades you can imagine from the
craftsman to the carpenter painter
carpenter
plastics processing people artists
digital specialists so basically
the whole  bandwidth we are also a
training company for highly attractive
professions around 200 trainees doing dual
studies meanwhile
the first professor
who did her training here has already started work
then the tourism university in
ravensburg so you can also
learn attractive professions which you can later learn in the  life
very well
brings in financial benefits but it's
probably not that easy
to cover this constant need for staff here now, around 5000 people and it's still
growing then I
'd like to know now park you hear a
lot of voices from people  those who don't
speak German
will certainly try
to settle people from all over the world here and of course that
was also the trigger of the crisis
. It's not unknown in Germany
that gastronomy services in
particular have lost a lot of jobs
because services are of
course also the most affected  was
by the pandemic and jobs have already
migrated that can also be seen
in the course of the older
life pyramid we have a
departure from
older target groups and less young people
who are growing up there there is a need for
demand and we can
no longer say that the
team can cover it  but
some of the employees come from
the eastern bloc now we have got 30
employees from southern italy we
even go as far as pakistan and kjaer 6
1 where you can find students with very good german training
and then several
hundred are hired by doctor of
course there is now an infrastructure
n  it's necessary that you accommodate them that
's a big challenge
in contrast when you get employees from
the region where you come back home in the evening
there are also a
lot of
houses where he just
the employees here for so many years through the
keyboard is of course after beds
it is very difficult to get employees
inside private rooms that
means the park has to invest so that
now a block of flats has been completed
and 200 apartments again a company kindergarten
had to be built in a
hurry  to satisfy the demand of our employees
and the hotels are
now economically the backbone
of the park how many rooms are there now
here it has actually developed very very
positively apps were the first
park in germany to have
a hotel room at all with a leisure facility of
course you need one  e certain
a certain offer so that
the internal night
that is created at all we
didn’t warm the hotels from the first hour the
first hotel only after about 15 years of
operation 20 busy ones
added the park was already
big enough that the hotel was the
same  was a success and today she has developed
the business model from it we
are no longer talking about parks but
about parks & resorts that means
the guests come today to take a short vacation
staying in our themed hotels
we decided early on hotels with
a theme of the holiday mood
mediated to build was absolutely the
right decision and meanwhile
it has become a business model
with the two parks with the water
bankrupt opec that you can change their course
okay but that means the hotels
are now also an economic backbone when you think about it
because that’s the
only thing  an absolutely absolutely because
we of course  rlich after extremely high
utilization of the railway and fans with high
utilization is a business model on all waves
which works very well
the ticket is
comparatively cheap you can get to the
park rhein denspitzen costs 10 60 euros
and then if it is not
peak times then  it is therefore
comparatively cheap if
you watch something in the cinema or a
stadium or if you take a ride on
a normal one in hamburg to the cathedral there
would have to be a bike somehow
not partially 12 15 euros then
we have to wait the whole day
and everything is clear as you think
about it now five million people make then 60
euros is already that would be a lot of money
but it still seems to me to be a lot
stronger and more calculable
if you say okay the hotels are
closed I have a
discussion  in our home in
syria, one is responsible for the
hotel business and the other is more
for the innovation and the frakti  one is
responsible and there is a fundamental
discussion who is more important for the
company likes to run the hotels
or who ultimately has the group i
think you can no longer
have that outside of it we now
also do big events like the cloud
festival
now conferences when it happens again  sometimes runs normally
where the park basically only plays a
secondary role and in the
main holiday season it is of course the
parka that brings people here and
sits their eyes on their necks the
guests simply need a holiday as a
holiday destination accommodation and
if the whole thing pays in  atmospheric
in the feeling i'm away from home
i'm in another world then
you scored well i think the
growth that
would have been possible without the hotels but of course the hotels also need
the dough and the
other hotels are now increasingly coming here
and say man  is somehow
necessary there is more demand here than than the
colleagues  n can lift it yourself the park
is there, we certainly would have had
that too we have now
hotel investors are going therefore
invested that maxi ad ybbs just opened a new
hotel then the
autobahn several hotels were
built that are 23 kilos away where you might be
in  is looking for the year-round offer
and ultimately also has a
business customer in mind, it is
exciting what has happened to hotel accommodation in
recent years, but we
were also drivers for the hotel
development on other days, not only
in Germany but throughout Europe
with the success of this one
many
colleagues have invested in the europa-park business models and
you would now like to open the hotel here or do you
think they will
take away our sales in the end I would rather build
ten more tel myself
we will certainly take the
opportunity in the  hotel offer still to grow
because of course we extend the
added value  Seeing the gskette
is interesting for us
and ultimately also what counts in the
experience value, however, that the hotel
can be a continuation of the atmosphere of the park,
but I'm still happy about every
further something that is created because it and
additionally brings frequency
and how is the use  the park is
currently planned like this for the year
so it is always full the park
also the hotels yes but i could
feel sorry for the park i heard there were about
40,000 people in it on certain days
it is really full on
summer days in during the holidays
performance management is also an issue
or where it is already at maximum
voice utilization is already an issue
now with the online ticket we can
control the flows a little better
that also has a learning effect
from the pandemic
it is clear we are a pure family
destination  what can the
weekend need and also the holidays
now we are in a region where both
the f  ranzosen at different
times that the swiss and also the
german holiday offer so
we have a relatively broad and larger
season to season extension that is for
a german partner central
germany is more difficult
if he just depends on a federal state in
whose holidays i think it has
When you first decide
to go here, you underestimate
not only that the sun certainly always
shines like it does today, but that we
also live in a holiday
landscape that offers different holiday
periods and therefore a fairly
balanced season also makes sense.
You can continue to close the park  build and
expand everywhere new topics will be
added there are also
forced to a certain extent in the industry because i
said before 80% of the repeaters
expect of course always emphasized
change in the offer new things and
the nice thing is with the hotels and if
the catchment area  becomes larger then
n  of course a much larger offer
also more attractive for guests to arrive
if you have maybe three four five
hours to travel and then stay
two three days yes
so investing in the
repeater also has the effect that the first-time visitor
with larger instructions has a much better
offer and where is it  since the end so
there is an international example, a
disneyland where are they now in
comparison to visitor volume and so
exciting that investments are made there again and again
and the parks are growing, of
course, several parks have also been
created there, so not only the classic
disneyland now exists
there is now also a film park in the
water park there are now centers and
much more universal in florida
is already building for the third day so
you are moving away from an even bigger
unit and going to a second
offer because in the end even the
daily offer no longer
allows it  that you just get too big
i  ch think we have to make it happen again here
that we exchange all the systems that are
outdated in the group
and replace them with innovative
rides or offers
that's certainly a point, but that we
have to keep investing
is definitely a given is basically a
comparison  is always out with the
fire if you don't put more wood
etc. but you say the park
the facility will continue to grow so that
as if you're thinking about it now there are
currently 56 million visitors that can
be pushed up to ten million and
then accordingly  build five six seven
hotels here is so that's
really the vision
yes of course you'll still reach
the limits of growth i mean that's the access road it's the junction of the
freeways we're
also in the process that we have better connections with japan they're
holding up
now  first ics also two kilometers away,
that means you travel in
egg today  A few hours from Frankfurt very
environmentally friendly and fast, but I
do believe that such a park
will eventually have a maximum size
because those are the hours the bar is
open, that's just the whole day,
it's the season or Shirin season
when there are no holidays  there is also
a
downturn that means we have to
see that there is an
economic balance between
bigger and frequencies just
to get big and then have a lot of weak
days you certainly don’t have a
business model what in the future
it will of course impose itself  that you
choose another location
with this experience [music] we are constantly being
asked to act as a co-investor or perhaps as an investor with this success during the apprenticeship years
i would say europe is
relatively well covered with parks
but there are also eastern europe  in the
other locations possibilities
currently we consider so that we  partly
designs with our companies with our
creative people where systems may also be
incorporated and will then act as a
supplier of amusement
rides as basically we pass on your
experience to the customers and
generate sales and orders for the
manufacturing company the im
moment and business model what will definitely work for
the next few years
there is one or the
other growing there but then it would
probably also be necessary
to think about going public to build a park today
you can no
longer make as small a shadow as it was back then
means you have to
decide to go public and i personally am
not a fan of going public
ok why can't you go to such
small states because
the people have traveled a lot they
know the industry many
have visited america we have been for a
few years  the little brother of the
painting paris it is in two hours
by thw from stra  ßburg in paris well
people know today what good
attractive parks look like and that's why
you could never say so small and
how we did it back then what are
the most important competitors in
europe was fc against holland you hear again and
again dissident paris what is still
relevant in europe i always compare myself
to the short travel destination in the
mediterranean sea that has nothing
to do with sex at first because i said it means yes
i am currently it ties up money
and i have the alternative i go on
a cheap plane for two three days  to
mallorca to spain or italy or
do i visit a theme park with my family
and in this respect every
free time is attractive that
is great that has
interesting offers and
takes time our competitor
you shouldn’t just
limit it to disneyland or the efteling
i would  say these parks
exist with a sufficiently large
distance are more of a
marketing effect for us  s if you have visited the
name that you now
let’s take a look at europa park
i think it attracts visitors rather than
taking visitors away from us if you’re
good and what’s what’s still
forgotten what so with the european pact
now, so to speak, none  eyes had
predicted tivoli copenhagen is a
very beautiful these two gothenburg magic
personally very fond of port aventura in
barcelona is a very beautiful park also
themed there are some very beautiful
facilities in
england whether the portal blackpool
also legoland to legoland
billund legoland we in germany are
attractive  offers in france
we have an asterix park cemetery scope there
are quite a few so we have around
500 million visitors in the
european parks and we have almost
a billion visitors in the parks
worldwide and they themselves then drive
through the parks and around the world
and take a look at it, thanks to
the internet, you're of course
faster on par these days  k even on the
factions because yes and videos gave
us a lot of information but of
course we ourselves also look at data
personally not least because we
also visit customers that’s
every park not only an innovator
but maybe also a source of ideas for us  is also a customer of
ours and in this respect the exchange is always
there are at the international trade fairs
where we see a lot of what is
happening worldwide whether it is Shanghai this year it
would be Hong Kong’s turn this year it is canceled for the third time
because of the pandemic it is in
Europe it will be  its london be
this year and the biggest
trade show in our industry is in orlando florida
and why is an ipo not a good
idea
i think i would be bad also
chairman of a 1000
oriented
company i think how we could do
our business with this
passion
you don't do that on the stock exchange for
no question if if you
growth b  smoke because you can't
finance yourself to ultimately be
successful on the market then you
have no other choice but
we can still draw the average
investment volume and also
the manpower that you need
for management from your own family and
then that's it for me at the moment
still the better model i was often a
discussion guest at banks when the
person was really big and was then one of
the few among them who spoke against fitting in
was precisely with
these arguments there we can handle the
average investment
volume and we have the successors and
then there is no reason
for me to go public the costs the
orphaned to in terms of sales
we knew that the company is now a
billion
and it is not growing well either
now we have had two years where things are
really good
and we are now extremely broadly
positioned not only that  would now be a
few hotels catering establishments, by the way,
the g  biggest casting location at one
point in germany no we have
meanwhile also taken on very modern
companies so that your lawyer we
bought a film production company in hannover make our own animated
film april are
on the move worldwide on offer with these articles
around it is integrating more and more
the  can you medially here in the park
a product that will be on the market in the next few weeks
is the restaurant of the
future adrenalin the entire
competence of the family business mark will be brought
to the table, starting with
media
content and gastronomic top offers and raise the emotions of the guests
through through the space of mack rides and
that's a lot of fun and i
think they are extremely well
positioned for the future, also to develop these offers
for others
and
maybe just get active in other parks away from the rust location
as a competent supplier not  still from
faction with de  r all the content we produced
the film for the
vitalium have
already added several films from kazakhstan
to mexico and are one of the best
film providers
on the market
as far as these flight simulators are concerned next
exciting exciting product and as
I said the next generation of them is
in  the starting blocks and it is absolutely
confident that even though the
credit market is general,
storytelling is an important
skill for you so if you think it’s
logistics and mechanical engineering and then
it’s kind of service but it’s also
content if you look at it that way  you
know there is a euro mouse here but
meanwhile there are a lot of
characters of course running around here
my favorite example was
that i could hardly believe there is a
ride that means by pirates in
batavia and there there is i was
told he is his person
bartholomäi means with the surname
you came up with  you then experience
and there he has an opponent so
it's a comic world again, a fantasy
world and there are a lot of them
so not so everywhere new
characters that he created come across so who
does something like that i think i cut a
great point like  also
family businesses move with the times
and
don't stand still but adapt new things
i told you before that
we just took nothing out of the drawer we didn't
bring any causal factors into the
first construction stage here but instead
everything was newly developed and that's how it works
again in the family  because the
subject of storytelling
books to produce
stories in the form of an
eldest son and that's what's
exciting in a family business
when these creative people are
there, in my opinion, it's the best
format you can offer to
families and also  not being anymore
when the talents run out is
certainly
leaving the weakest  families can live our lives
2000 oriented company then it is
easier because the people
from germany can
not always but usually get the right people on board
that is of course important in a
family company that it comes out more
from the inside although we are
now many  Managers and
responsible people from the outside in the
leadership in Dicke but are they agreeing to
a state that
explicitly tells stories with incredible love for detail
that I think it's a
decorations in these figures and
it's also the case that sometimes
the stories  still be passed on in books and with
digital understand
nothing namely goes into his
country and then you meet the people
can buy a children's book then the
child can then
continue reading it at home or read it in advance then this
is real alleged living environment this
this  find fantasy characters and
that was it  idea of my son and therefore inves
ed and that is certainly corre
t how can you bring this park into
he children's room and to the victi
s if the customer is not with us and t
at exactly the interface is known retai
ing via videos that are created via audio
books via books  pictures books and
much more
up to the theming in the park also to have
innovation and also in the
unique selling points and I
think that is now the 360 degree appro
ch the gig needed so far has recog
ized it relatively quickly he of course comes from
he film industry and he was
he was always aware he
went to the customer with the film
we also do it of course but
with europe the customer would have to come to
us and we only really got the 360 degree approach right in th
next generation, altho
gh it was already clear to me  we need
theming, we need symbolic figures and we also need stories,
but that's it  t now
perfected and implemented with arthur and many
more
grandiosely in
general you have the feeling what is also
important is somehow this role of
the family as hosts so I now
check in a hotel
attach pictures of you with other
celebrities to the elevators do not fall
who are in love themselves
you know where you are so the
marx family is actually standing at the door, so to speak,
a bit symbolically
in arms or with her
children the feeling was here i am
at the family market although of
course that's a huge thing
it's right because you say and i
think that makes the big difference
i can remember the time when
walt disney founded the park
tata also had a small apartment because it is
on american street
and mainz  a bathrobe walked across the
street the bakeries
got his rolls there and an
hour later you could see him sitting on the train
that was still walt
disney that today managers are no
longer available and i can always
feel when i am with these people  also have
to do with business how much
you bring the volt forward
again bring it to life and present it
as a family and that is exactly
what makes europa park
stand out here is a face behind the company
look we don't
transport sandbags  but people children
families and i think that's a
confidence-building measure if you
know when you're in charge of the park and that it's
a family here that is concerned with the
topic and the topic of safety and the
topic of quality that's
confidence-building and insofar a
friend of mine  once said it
's like you're in the neighbor's
garden when his wonderful sentence because
it's not quite at home but you
feel at home and if you
manage to do that i think that's also the
secret of europa-park's woman of success
that you almost feel at home
but with many other suggestions
you feel  probably that's what you want to come
back to if you ask
why i mr mack myself i
have your colleagues that's not as
asked as i said he lives
behind grimm's fantasy world or something like that he
has his house so some people
would have wanted that  you now, so to speak, directly
i didn't copy that either
it just happened that way look at the
families and then someone experienced in the
company right in the middle we have already i
told you before so looked at a bedroom
house saw the carousels
turning and then out and
I got on board myself and I think it
became clear relatively quickly that we
live here and I used to live in the middle of the park, right in the middle of
it all  r
a bit tight below council
office above the apartment and next to it
the information so there was no private person at all lived in the
castle again for a few
years that she was out and
several times less in the middle and now that she was
not at home between sleeping beauty and
snow white
a bit at home  I'm late
with my finger and then
I know for sure it's time for
a special guest but it's
kind of a wish that one day
I'll say I've got a house that's a
bit gaga or somehow in Mallorca
or something like that  then you
somehow really ended up to yes
sometimes you can stay on at night yes of
course we have alternative
options and for years we
always try to go on vacation
no question but meanwhile if you are
so big with the growth then of course you ca
n’t let go of the company
but  I don't even know what they
said looking for a job that's
really fun b  wrestling then my
whole life wouldn't have to work
i think it's extremely true for me
it's passion it's fun it
's joy and sometimes when i
look back then it was
actually years ago i was just there
but youngest and when i'm in the
world today  drum cook is no longer on the one
she from can still be found
everything has been retired for decades or
in the cemetery and i
sometimes feel like
methusalem when i started here 50 years ago
how quickly this time flies that
also has to do with the fact that  you
actually liked going to work almost every day
which wasn't you
will now stop 72 today
obviously you can stay young even with a lot of
work
i think mind and
body are also trained driven
by work-free plan if it
's fun for you and me
can only give it to everyone as
a recommendation to
look for a job was fun then
don't feel that al  s such and
life actually goes around too quickly
then you are there the new topics
instagram and generally digital question
that’s probably what your sons are doing yes
you have to do that you notice the
generational change i absolutely see
that it’s important and that the
company needs it and  that it will also lead
into the near future
but you have to be passionate about a topic
like i was passionate about when
this park was set up this
topic will not be burning i'm not interested in
it i think it's right and
i will  also
accompany and fully support it also
economically and it needed
people who are passionate about the topic that does
the next generation but i think it
's great and that's also the
chance to
open new doors and
to lead the company in a new era and
now, so to speak, at the end  to say the
journey was now the start at the big
anniversary party but pandemic that's
also blatant than that si  you should
n't have expected it, so to speak, and you can read
that somehow you can calculate it
probably
cost the company several hundred million, so
the campaign that caused the closure to be temporary,
but
that could still be easily
removed,
yes, the company is good at
that too  my
father always preached to me liquidity before
profitability
don't spend the last euro so as not
to fall into the hands of the banks
that of course gave itself to him
as a construction worker although he
invested heavily at the same time
but built up reserves
and then  very organized got through these
pandemics more than
100 million lost sales will be the
chance to the chagrin of my
employees, of course, and it was
sad for me sending loyal employees on short-time work
was just a huge
challenge for my employees,
but with that you could have an impression
of liquidity  construction
slowed down  t to continue to keep his reserves
but after i noticed
also through contacts to china who were
a bit ahead of us in the
pandemic the business model can continue to
exist even after the
pandemic we were relatively confident
and continued to invest even in
the pandemic  just then to
be prepared for afterwards now that’s going to be quite
easy to shake off have really had a
difficult time we had first
the big fire with almost 80 million
tanks in the evening then the pandemic and now
the wars in the
ukraine okay i say yes and the war is having an
effect too  because of course
the prices are going up everywhere now and that the
budget that people have for
vacations is probably not that big anymore
,
right, although i think that we
are still doing well in the competition
because it is a manageable one not
with the car
can take the train i'll be home relatively quickly around the world
that's an over  manageable
budget with a good price-performance
offer for the whole family and in
this respect i believe that we could be the beneficiaries even
in difficult times
but it must not go on for too long
and it would of course also be important
to have energy security and ultimately
also affordable ones  to have energy because
the park is already in energy consumption
although with almost 30 percent more than
producing environmentally friendly energy and more and more in the future
yes it would
be appropriate to look carefree and look ahead
again it has been 34
years now that we are so in  one crisis after the
next and it burned like it
was then i would just
probably the biggest misfortune in the park
is that's why he hasn't had any major
personal believe i could never
see myself then the fire was the
biggest thing that happened here yes that  was
the largest
subject areas were destroyed by fire for several years  n
and it could not be stopped but
thank god no human
lives were harmed no emergency management worked excellently
but
it was of course a feat of strength to rebuild
this large facility in such a short
time and we did it well
and everything was fine  it was finished
the pandemic came
and ok ok but well i mean
at least such fires they
probably all insured and
there you have economy again not exactly
that applies that everything went well but of course it
was in addition to the construction of the
water price we were building at the same
time  the
finalization of this major investment near europa
park with roland egger that came about at the
same time as the fire for a while so it was
an extreme challenge from armin
power and can also be operated rapidly must be
operated in parallel with major
cuts we managed it quite well
then  you can also
read it somehow when it burned there
h  at is on saturday then of course there was the
fire brigade and everything we see you live
then at night they said we'll
open again tomorrow it's also 19 the woman
contacted the police because they looked deep into their eyes
they were very doubtful but then
like that  it takes a minute for someone
to come forward and say it has to be like
that, i'm sending families and
children home who were looking forward to this
day and are probably
already
thinking about going back there, but we'll try that
and we've got it  managed
and just mentioned is gives the
romantic this is this water world so
a
leisure pool you could say but the
massive dimensions and
slides and all the trimmings wave parks who
comes up with such an idea so how
do you sit together we do you sit there in the
evenings and  say to your wife now a
water park like it or of
course we observed that
i already said before the destination
has to  which will become more attractive and
this will take time to be expanded through
offers and then of course you can
already see what’s coming there everything is possible is it
a museum is it a sporty
offer for me is it a water offer is the
water offer author indoor
it needs to form themes more are needed for that
hotels and a final vote,
we then came to the conclusion with experts also
from the family circle it is about a
high investment
that in the water park is the right
decision and i just
yesterday i
received the documents from our
annual visitor survey the documents
gets our
annual both the abstention where you can see because there was
a big big concern, such a
water basin could cannibalize the offer of the
europa-park, that means
they interest Serbs money in a
new facility and
refinance it with a loss in
the old facility and it is  unbelievable
the cannabis effect we have  through
our science which we
ask is practically zero
but it leads exactly to what
we wanted that the guests say
we will visit both and briefly
allow that means we will now
continue to put pressure on the beds
and will be able to use both facilities to
capacity  this announcement
so the long search for the
right solution also
paid off what an
investment volume of
magnitude but to build its experienced space we are
now planning and
invested 250 million 250 million and that was what you
said before you ca
n't today  more small start with the
water price it didn't work without him because
if we decided for an indoor
solution that means then you
need at least a deep look at
your number of visitors and according to this number of
visitors you need to
go to the hall and an infrastructure
and with that comes an
investment volume  together
would be the same ever  Now when you start a new park
you probably know because
you can expect a visitor and
accordingly you have to align your investments
accordingly because today many
people know what the park offer is of
course the connection between the number of
visitors without the
investment volume is already significant if
you want to play attractively but what
in normal operation, the
main cost drivers are personnel energy
depreciation on the
invested parts these are the main
biggest carriers and sales are then now
tickets accommodation
gastronomy hotel industry or
events of any form that
we have we have the committee we have
concerts that we offer so there  is
there still a value-added chain
that runs parallel to the classic days
over 1000 guest a guest event
because here are in yes yes yes and from small
to large it starts
with birthday parties
weddings company events knight's meal
evening events any  art
themes festivals then our slide show, which
runs very successfully from mid-
november to mid-
february or early march, where we serve a
top-class
show program with good food with very
good food we also
have star gastronomy on board here and she
saw herself with the  sky
has defended the second star for several years
there is already a wide
range of offers and of course what
we also notice there seems to be a
realist pouring in to give the advertising
means you have partnerships there
are if you walk through the park and
look closely there are still  once a
puma shop here or there are somehow
from different clothing companies who
then have shops like that are very nicely
integrated into the system but
suddenly there was a film from munich or
you then somehow have an
easter bunny from lindt or there are
different ones  that's how integrated
partnerships and i call it
strategic partnerships that us  on
the one hand, of course, to address all possible
target groups through their area of
bution, which we would not otherwise reach at all if I
ow l
gally switzerland swiss
guests we naturally come into a lot
of shops through compe
itions sponsoring through partn
rships or our partn
rship with the freiburg sports club put y
ur external  partnership
or the long cooperation with
mercedes where we are in the area of the sporty offer
from mercedes to vehic
es that we put on the market together here vehic
e presentation so it opens up a
uge range of opportunities for a spons
r in the form of marke
ing measures that you  otherwise wouldn't
have without the partner but i mean
that means there is a cooperation
but at the same time it's
probably possible to earn a lot of money
with it it's just that these
companies are allowed to have their shops here that they are the ark of
these millions of
contacts  to be nerated simply
make them available to others
but strategic partnership that is
so hot strategic partners in the
valley best if it pays off for both
partners
as much as possible with less effort every day than if he were
to do it alone and insofar no
partnerships never work
either  strategic partnership if
i address the same target
groups if the partner is
not
also very interested
in gaining a foothold here with us that the reasons are
probably interested in
selling things here and making presence but
also brands your brand known
i think we have your
international  audience again free time
mood very like young people
internationally that
is very exciting for puma
that should also
run the business but not run the
business ourselves we only have the
items from tuna even now in no
economical point of view there is one here too
but also run the business again,
okay
, we have eyes on the situation that they
want to sell adventure experiences there
and that of course fits very well with
what the park also tries
to sell as adventure experiences,
so we basically have a
similar approach to what they
when
it comes to addressing customers, there is no such thing as a really classic one on the market and
it has to be operated in
bercy or there is a
real partnership although they say
okay i just have a department that
allows local companies to
do something about it  kassel is doing
all the business itself at the moment, whether it’s the
hotels or our
sales businesses, they’re controlled and operated by the company
, okay, that’s to say,
letting people know that it will be easier for them
to set up other companies,
we have that philosophy too  only the
possibility to make
product changes
changes at all  to
do if you do it with a partner lessee
gartner others think there also thinks
finally there also thinks too specifically about
his product here the whole
thing counts of course in the overall idea 1
we also learned that in the usa there is also at
disney basically can hardly
partners who act independently there
but that everything is done under the
leadership of disney that
starts with the product
presentation with the costumes the demented
employees with the training of the
employees it's just important to have a
holistic appearance in his park
and
we actually did
n't say anything about that  have also learned
that this is the right way to go if you are
talking about this now so have the
feeling that there is already a
certain orientation somewhere but at the same time
if you look at it you have now won the
prize there is probably
a prize in the industry for that
best amusement park in the world than me
place egg  ns in europa park i can't
do that well at
some point the big formula 1 goal but
i pay my fees in mutual respect
and i admire again and again
the parks but with
what consequence and in what
dimension that's something
where you can also mutual  i
mean the parisians look at rust today
and we look at my paris and we
chat and exchange
experiences and i always said the best
combination would have been if walt
disney and my father had
met then you would have the
club and we
had to make the great rides so disney
and harry had to choose whether to go to san
francisco and we
also had to buy the first films now
we make the films ourselves and one does
n't build any rides yet but
it already has  try this
combination, of course, it will be
something else, what you do, it's too late, that's
kei  n family business more and both
the two seniors are already
in the cemetery ok mind and they will take it over to
the next generation that
means they
will hand it over step by step at some point
and then you keep the background
but another ten years of research a good
goal we have a family constitution
made the last few years where we
have also established these these points
that we want to remain families and
that we have certain ideas
when someone works in family
businesses how their contribution should be
who is almost 250 years old i mean
i am here the seventh generation the
next the  the eighth generation is
fully integrated also as a shareholder
and managing director
the hope that things will continue well in the next
generation is
great that assumes that
the framework conditions that work will then remain the same
for arguing
as we have then i do
n’t see any there  problem
still are  you
still really and it's
a family business so that
if your health allows it you
gradually transfer responsibility
that hamburg started in
time then as I said you
still have to put up with one or the other setback with the fire with
the pandemic, probably mine, of course
life experience professional experience was already
very helpful for the next
generation
but the process is ongoing and the
operative business is being transferred more and more to the
next generation. is
n't it also the thought of the pandemic?
one might then
perhaps have to diversify a bit more
all the risk of the
family in such large investments every year
everything in one park here in
this area already the company is
also involved here or sells a similar
business at least
others also travel so you have the feeling
that there is of course almost a
concentration of risk somewhere or does it exist
separate in  furniture evening that you
operate whereby suitcase apartment
worldwide something like that is well meant here
in life you have to decide on one
thing and I said yes
I said relatively faster that the
business model europa-park short trip
destinations can also exist after the pandemic
and if  looking back
we often discuss it when you do something
yesterday in a country like the
usa now more than 60 70
years old
parks bloom worldwide if they are
done well i think the topic of
entertainment
in
the working world close to the
working world will always exist
of course you have to be careful that the
offer does not go unnoticed by the customer
and my credo every day is to
blame the company from the guest if you
diversify the question is whether you are
then just as strong in the other
areas as when you
concentrate we were the  opinion
concentrate make the best of
what you imagine every day  take and with that
you have the greatest chance of
survival in the west that i
would have thought now really will be
death here somehow on the roller
coaster there are in the
world that is a roller coaster
another glass or something or
leaving japan and that once  then in the
press the news would also be very
difficult although a that well of
course it is also important that the
question of guilt is clarified that you are not
personally
accused that you were
careless if you
comply with the regulations complying with the maintenance
regulations is not a risk
it can definitely be ruled out, but if
you know that the risk of accidents on roller
coasters and on fast
fractions is significantly lower than
driving a car or other transport systems,
then the picture becomes a bit
crazy because of course we have an
accident in a park or in a
ride he is on the
but he appears on the front page ic  h tell me again
there is no such thing as a risk-free
life when you are born you know
that at some point you will arrive at the cemetery
maybe not quite thematically a
good ending but let's almost have a
bad conscience i always
thought when i bring the rockstar is
the best here  every
day the company also has a huge chance to
continue to exist and of
course if you play up a few points
you have to be careful not to put them in too
much of a position but to
make sure that it doesn't happen
through careful measures through
clean controls  through constant
training of the staff through
tüv approvals and much more
safety checks
, you also have a residual risk, but if you
sit on the train or drive a car to
hamburg in front of others, you
probably also have a risk and then you
should perhaps consider whether
you should come to me
we will stay in any case very nice
days that
you really don't have to
worry i'm extremely inspired and
enthusiastic about what we
've built here with the
spirit and the thinking about it and
also the willingness to take risks it's so
unbelievable for me to have
been allowed to be here and here these  being able to ask
questions what was it really so much fun and thank you very much
for being
then yes that was really fun too
and sometimes they
even made me think that i
always push some people away with the daily routine
and it's a good thing  den maxis
lars is actually always half full and
not half empty
thank you very much this podcast is
produced by portsmouth
at mr